accountability my friends you put
accountability on a pedestal your life
will change do you know how liberating
it is when you realize everything's your
fault it gets real [ __ ] good out here
anything happens at vaynermedia that's
broken my fault you know why I hired the
person like yeah I get it that Sally is
a [ __ ] guess what I hired her I'm
obsessed with practicality everything I
talk about feels so real it just might
take 11 years and a lot of people don't
have 11 years they don't have 11 years
because they're not wanting to put him
to work to be happy for the rest of her
life they'd rather complain they'd
rather blame somebody else
team it was my player teammates fault
school [ __ ] the teachers right work my
boss is a [ __ ] idiot
I have never lost and blamed anything
else but myself
I love accountability I love
accountability I'm disrespectful to
entitlement and I put accountability on
a pedestal we want to blame everybody
but our [ __ ] selves we have zero
[ __ ] accountability you have
subconscious bias deal with it period
when you actually realize everything's
your fault it gets really good out here
because when you think your boss's boss
controls your [ __ ] when you think
somebody down the street in a building
controls your [ __ ] then you get real sad
because you feel helpless when you
realize you control your [ __ ] things
[ __ ] go it doesn't mean that
everything like when I say everything's
my fault it doesn't mean that that's
true it means that it's just a happy
place to think about it feels empowering
you know like people get mad at me
they're like Gary what about what about
like you're right you know buddy those
things happen to me but there's a
million outside forces but like you know
it's really exciting to be able to think
about like I could possibly do something
about this while to your point earlier
still recognizing like whether it's
grieving or being disappointed about it
you have to be able to do that but it's
just you two
it's like what's the alternative I think
accountability is very important you
know everything on you everything's your
fault
you want to really win in life you want
to get real happy you know I'm really
happy cuz I think everything is my fault
if I don't like it I can change
everything wrong at vaynermedia anything
that ever happens any piece of content
anything that ever happens in my life
100 [ __ ] percent is my fault and let
me tell you what happens with
accountability you get real happy when
you feel that there's no other source
controlling your [ __ ] all of a sudden it
gets happier if you complain in the
first hour I meet you you're finished
yeah I think complaining is the TEL and
if you ask me right now what's going on
with my content there's a really
interesting vibe going on because it
must be the cadence of our content I'm
getting so much content from people that
are happy out of depression right now
and I cannot tell you how many of them
are completely predicated on the fact
that they don't make excuses anymore
and they've taken 100% accountability I
genuinely think it's the unlock of
happiness when you think it's all your
fault what you realize is that nobody's
in control and all of a sudden you get
happy well I just don't know how to
complain I always think somebody has it
worse and if somebody has it worse you
need to shut up whoever is the
seven-point-seven if that's the number
we're at whoever's in last place whoever
that person is if there was a world
chart ranking and Sally was dead last
she can talk
[Music]